les honneurs live on est parti
le tweet est lancé
bonjour à tout le monde pour la
rediffusion
alors est-ce que c'est ce que s'est
lancé dans mon truc ici aussi
ça va peut-être faire un petit écho je
te laisse parler quand je regarde si je
mens pas si longtemps pour le voir tout
le monde en sort pour mon jeu vendredi
soir à tous
parfaits et puis voilà saurez vous
retrouver avec le maître twitch
et encore j'ai encore un padawan c'est
encore dans le le lessivage il pas
encore et 6,20
changer le logo envergure mais on en a
bien plus beau que ça fera moins que je
le dit
salut joe installe-toi tranquillement
j'espère que tu as passé une bonne
semaine et que ton équipe est en train
de faire des traits de ouf comme
actuellement le fond les plaisirs et
les noami watts est le seul mec de
france a trouvé ce deal bon pour pour
pourtant marc almalik yonne c'est pas
c'est pas c'est pas un bouddhiste
important de surtout pour une équipe qui
essaie d'être compétitive au départ avec
avec des miennes il a de même
piaggio des parents compliments non mais
pjanic très très chaud de sudîles enfin
quoi
là actuellement si john hughes bourgeois
et si nous voulons venez vous êtes bien
je suis extrêment envergure en vous
inquiéter jean paul ii et pie ou
sélectif et mais le temps que vous
installez et signalez vous donne lieu de
ça quand on vous fait des bisous mais là
il va en gros y'a qui de mieux que lui
sur le poste de fort worth aux blessures
d'actuellement qui est dispo y a
personne je pense qu'il est ce qu est ce
que c est ce que c'est un faux un taux
d'informalité d'en faire un des trois
français un deux trois et ça lui
est d'accord il va devoir jouer c'est
bon c'est ça depuis cent ans finalement
sans trop de pression vu que je pense
que les blés de revivre un peu près tout
casser si vous êtes fans des blazers on
est désolé en honneur le choix on est là
pour vous dites vous que vous avez
récupéré un super gars vous avez
récupéré nasir little qui s'est joué au
basket
le vélo directement c'est parti ouais
ouais ça m'avait manqué
aux jo je savais que j'allais être là
directe arrive que c'est ça y est c'est
aujourd'hui on parle de ton de ton
copain une chose qui dit on te l'avait
promis on y est enfin
allé dit aux gens ça des premiers
condamnation après le premier live ça
lui va quoi ça installe toi ça fédère
notamment pour la première fois sur
notre live après premier la bonne avait
dit qu'on avait parlé de wendell moore
et de evans m'oblige crown avait dit le
prochain c jaws qui dit eh bah
finalement on est là on a pris le temps
et moi l'émotion de ce titre
en corse les 7 3 minutes en vue
de nous suivre c'est cool de t'avoir
alors t'as vu j'ai rajouté j'ai rajouté
une alerte pour savoir maintenant quand
les gens il nous faut l'eau etc parce
que
à vous régaler auger lui des zombies je
trouve que fait c'est le truc de base et
je trouve que ça ça n'est pas près notre
état physique quand la vidéo date des
musts de kiss de pacte web de npl
way vue des championnats du championnat
espoirs des fois être un tuner d'espoir
en plus la plupart du coup c'est ça
je le suivais déjà dans les trains qui
vont suivre bah ouais il ya je profite
des vacances scolaires pour
essayer d'aller faire les tournois en
europe régal et donc l'euro ligue junior
s'appelle lundi d'un exode generation
allen j'étais là où été jérémy sociable
l'an dernier notamment sa valeur qui
monsieur qui joue avec eux tu vois où il
ya des tournois super intéressant pour
la nba pourrait initier voit on va
essayer d'aller voir d'aller voir ça
c'est la règle commune on sait pas trop
mais ont baissé tu pars avec qui tu pars
avec ton copain de toujours dit qu on m
votre service et le suisse ont joué je
suis son simple simple thriller c'est un
peu simples mortels
non mais c'est cool comme ça que tu
fasses un petit tour d'europe et tous ne
me trouvais ça fait c'est cool d'avoir
là il s'est vraiment vraiment un super
intéressant quand on a l'occasion
c'est intéressant at il dit pendant les
échauffements plein de choses qu'on peut
attendre 15 ans à deux balles surtout
pour des jeux tu peux vraiment tout ce
qui se dit et c'est
complètement puis c'est un mec
malheureusement il joue que cinq minutes
parce qu'il a 15 ans et qu'en fait tu
aimerais bien devoir ou 16 ans battue
peut le voir pas à l'échauffement donc
jamais une idée globale sur un genre
mais toujours des éléments qui peut
prendre grâce à tarbes
améliorer la vision du jour on veut dire
c'est clair c'est que la plainte que
nous alors pour les gens qui arrivent
sur le live dub bienvenue je vois qu'il
ya plein de nouveaux feux de sa fille
hyper plaisir installez-vous
tranquillement
on avait eu la chance d'avoir de voir le
asbl contre le paris basket et on avait
pu voir justement les jeunes à un peu
avant on avait l'espoir on avait
envisagé un avis fusent et diawara
malvoyants il a fêté rabat elle ne vit
pas comme dadié
qui également loyal kalt super prof
peine 2000 5 français
c'était bien cool est prêt pour le coup
de l'exorciste scouter ans de prendre
des notes en direct est vraiment très la
différence bien plus de 20 points à
l'abattement parce que tu es dans le
flot du match au plus tard assuré
merci
remercier tous les tous les faux l'eau
parce qu'il a beaucoup de celles hyper
cool
mais merci notre cas de les hacher je ne
sais pas si tu as même écart est
titulaire en euros l'hectare pour la
dixième fois j'ai vu trop de points 16
ans j'ai vu tout de suite de la seule il
faut tourner une équipe à une équipe un
peu secondes wen doit y avoir pas mal de
soucis même pas mal de problèmes mais
bon quand même notable mais c'est trop
bien ouais c'est donc simplement sa note
sur la régulation devait parler de
nicolas lang il était très très au
dessus
et je dis c'est qu'effectivement nous si
on avait bien kiffé le voir que un ex
miss asia qui
voit la maman c'est la petite pépite
française depuis pas mal de temps ce qui
s'était fait couler tout ce qu'on veut
bien sûr je les ai faites les jours où
le coût de la visite était aussi à
l'euro près 16 et tous les américains
tous les
mecs qui sont là pour l'assiette et
s'est arrêté pas laisser dire donc on a
récupéré demandé dans les glaces pas
possible qu'il érige où il va jouer il
va jouer pro ou non c'est impossible
n'est pas grosse grosse cote les hf 6 2
exactement mon fils de deux médaillés
olympiques
papa stéphane risacher c'était fin les
acheter c'est ça qui était déjà un
énorme shooter journée dans le bois des
mémoires seront trop petit pour sa trop
jeune mais je construirai fêté un peu le
on aime ça alors oui la chaleur parce
que je n'ai que très mal sûrement
comment tu les fais que je me trompe ri
est à ça à faire un jeu décrié rio comme
du riz tu harissa chez moi j'ai écrit on
n'est pas du tout a résumé liste de
courses actuellement donc c'est pas le
même de dire
sa carri zachary effectivement voilà la
page en régime avec les suivre notre ami
vous voyez un profil très très long
deux mètres 0-2 qui joue du café le
matin 16 ans
il ya un article déjà qui est sorti on
aller par la turquie d'un nom même ce
sera la haine il est
exact
ok bon bah écoute on va pouvoir on va
pouvoir y aller on a fait une petite
minute comme ça notre de discussion ça
fait toujours du bien pour ceux qui nous
rejoignent ce soir alors vous voyez dans
le dans le titre du stream et puis vous
si vous avez la commande play pour ceux
qui nous rejoignent on va parler ce soir
de deux joueurs un qui joue en nba josh
qui dit l'australien qui est du coup un
des porteurs de balle à de nombreux
porteurs de vol du côté de d'oklahoma
city et on va aussi parler de
l'inévitable de là mon cap de la tondue
chat en grève on va essayer de remettre
un peu de jeu vous êtes riche matin pour
vous dire un petit coucou on va essayer
un peu de mètres de respect sur le nom
de tête en grès ne dis pas que le mec
qui a battu victoria qui s'est fait
battre par victor une bonne humeur à ce
qu'il paraît s'est fait dominer par même
town manière c'est ça donc c'est un
énorme prospects
du côté de gonzaga et ce soir on va on
va mettre un peu de respect on va faire
un tour à cana est meilleur que son beau
succès
on nous dit quitter peste une panne
passé lego il ya moyen moyen c'est un
passeur extraordinaire un passeur fin
devient un grand passeur mois joueurs
honnêtement bon allez dessus mais que
j'avais un peu raté parce que l'an
dernier la une bielle c'était pas ma
priorité ce n'est pas vraiment ma tasse
de thé c'était pas si accessible que ça
il y avait un peu de politique ses
terrasses étaient j'avais moins violent
et moins vu dieuze qui dit je pense que
la boucle est bouclée en 2021 c'était
déjà un truc de vieux en 2021 si vous
utilisez ferme nouveaux fans ce que
j'attendais matcher tik tok mois avec
des traînées dans sera incroyable
en direct du trajet ce père que la kova
tenir et bah écoute c'est vous qui ne
suivent en train et j'espère que ton
pote trajet va bien se passer et puis si
jamais la replay sera disponible cet été
sur le tu ne t'en fais pas de quoi tout
ce qu'il dit toujours qu'on avait
peut-être un peu moins vu
que d'autres puisqu'il avait joué moins
de matches que la n 6 est beaucoup plus
visible et caetera et qui réalise un
très très beau début de saison très beau
début de carrière
on va laisser le choix au chat on est on
est on est en live 100% connu comme
disent les gros streamer est ce que vous
préférez qu'on lance avec josh qui dit
où est ce que vous préférez qu'on lance
avec piano comme dit nous nous dans les
commentaires je paie ses deux lancers de
lancer un sondage que j'ai jamais fait
de ma vie
avec quelqu'un qui arrive directement
première fois guy dit qui dit chet à
d'ingrédients me lie à la cour pour les
programmes par la communauté d'hôpitaux
4 a maintenant un truc le cas c'est le
foot est devenu je les ai pas notifié
situe plus d'otages les délais ne tienne
on est à 2 2 la d2 monsieur parent on
part serein sur du tennis ans
et un break pour qui est la nôtre
partout
faut appeler pierre est constant et ben
voilà à l'aller il va appeler pierre et
constant constant et pierre marie jo pas
comment ces partis est un fan doc et 6
kg dit je suis chaud pour commencer par
chet tu vois c'est
c'est c'est bien joué c'est beau jeu
diddy diddy diddy mais je pense qu'on va
partir chant qui dira le peuple réclame
10 10 moi je suis là pour le peuple vous
inquiétez pas on fera les frais les deux
tu penses à l'avenir bien vue
commence le futur c'est maintenant allez
on va partir sur notre ami georges didi
et puis on ferait on fera tout y est
après
jack goody du coup comment le
déclencheur envergure déjà il était ici
il était décrit comme un point guard
shooting guard il faudra déjà à l'époque
on savait pas trop ce qu'on savait ce
qui portait le ballon c'est un créateur
extraordinaire qui venait de ce train
dit
donc 2 mai 03 86 kg je sais pas si les
stats elles sont
actualisées en tout cas c'est les stades
qu'ils avaient du côté de l'agneby
allemagne el hadj pour un peuple un bon
on connaît le dopage améridiens toi
juste sur ce joueur qu'est ce que tu
connaissais qu'est ce que tu sais ce que
tu l'avais un peu entendu parler avant
l'année de carême la banque 2021 et moi
c'est quoi ton retour
ouais en gros des mémoires il y avait
deux coqueluches australienne qu'il
fallait suivre à 2021 c'était josh
guider et c'était manger avec qui me
coûte chef qui
mangeait avec kim qui avait une grosse
balle de break dans le milieu un peu
embrouillé draft twitter hipster et tous
et qui a un peu déçu donc il est même il
s'est même pas présente à la draft il
est encore en nba de cette année moi
j'ai un viking
beaucoup ensuite parlé de dyson daniels
en fait jean daniel s'il avait un an de
moins j'en savais pas trop où il jouait
finalement by s'engager avec des
leggings night mais un an après et donc
josh guidée à lui ça a été un peu
rapidement le mec a été mis en avant par
par son club donc là delayed par la nba
dans général highlight tout ça et
ensuite il avait aussi le jeu et les
performances offensives pour faire ce
aussi ressortir très rapidement et c'est
vrai que c'est un les premiers images et
dont je n'ai vu que en nba il avait joué
du fiba je convaincs fiba championnat
océanie j'avoue que je suis très fan des
championnats jeunes mais aussi bas
océanie j'ai jamais essayé de regarder
peut-être qu'un jour je regarderai avec
plaisir mais je n'ai pas regardé donc
que nba ou été un peu mis en avant en
tant que porteur de balle et je le
trouve un truc que j'ai vu c'est ou à la
créativité de passe la capacité à faire
des passes des deux mains comme sfr
dépassa qui sont une main demain gauche
- droite est
un joueur de grande taille en athlète
négatif ce que je pense toujours
un genre ultra talentueux c'est moi qui
fait fonctionner ton attaque donc pour
moi un certain plafond pour l'ennemi ce
que j'ai beaucoup sur un mec comme la
meinau je compare pas les joueurs mais
la meinau je trouvais toujours qu'on
avait une idée assez négative de lui
parce que on ne disait pas contre ont
tous et qu'il n'avait pas au plancher
mais pour moi c'est l inverse parce que
hélas est déjà en australie il perdait
peu de ballons pour beaucoup passent
alors qu'il est bien un jeu à risque
échec en nba il allait faire même si le
tir allait pas être là-bas au moins j'ai
ramé qui pouvait créer beaucoup d'
attaque générer de l'attaqué c'est un
peu ce qui est guidé je trouve
c'est vrai que pour le coup quand je
dirais développer le fait de négatif
c'est quoi par ce biais c'est sur
l'explosivité sur la verticalité sur la
verticalité l'explosivité le premier pas
ouais je trouvais aussi son randonne
bizarre très bizarre de jouer alan doyle
paille pas méga fonctionnel pas
académique
donc voilà mais un joueur et rose
atypique voilà atypique c'est sur ces
notes de tarentules qui pouvaient qu'ils
maîtrisaient le ballon qui qui avait
braqué leurs mots des gros flash et tout
et on puisse silva les données là il
aurait physique et encore une première
image tu te dis pas ok lui c'est un
joueur fléchi que pouvait l'être la mélo
qui qu'il émane de lui et ça je retiens
est très surprenant si on regarde un
petit peu de alex me disais alors déjà
alex
il avait faim l'éducation scouting
report il avait très chaud le truc en
disant qu' il a vu dans différents
contextes équipe nationale d'australie
parce que c'est un joueur qui avait joué
avec son équipe nationale alors qu'il
est très très très jeune et raul palu 18
ans vraiment l'équipe des dépôts des
pros
et ensuite du coup au niveau d'adélaïde
pour faire rapidement il disait qu'il
était très grande il y avait des styles
qui progressaient tout le temps quelque
chose qui l'a qu'il avait marqué qu'à
chaque fois qu'il le voyait il y avait
de l'évolution que c'est un joueur qui
était précis propre en descend à
travailler parler du pick and roll est
ce que c'était un joueur qui pouvait
justement accéder au panier ce qui
pouvait prendre un tir est ce qui
pouvait j'appelle le campo trouver le
big le haendel lui aussi trouvé cabaret
de l'un peut un peu particulier le tir
la créativité les mettez en descend
alors que c'est quand même quelque chose
qui ressort très souvent chez guy 10 et
qui sortent souvent des parce que ta
tombe pas et parfois que ses coéquipiers
n'attendent pas non plus le point de
faibles qu'elles rouvrent fois-ci impact
défensif effectivement nous fixe très
frêle pour le moment du côté d'oklahoma
c'est grave de dire oklahoma state
oklahoma city on a effectivement une
équipe très très jeune qui était font
très peu donc c'est difficile de juger
vraiment guy dit là dessus un truc
compétitifs ce qui m'intéresse aussi
c'est regarder l'an dernier vous avez
sorti votre mac votre bord donc 2021 y
avait peu de toi forcément ben may nul
et donc alex et le consensus était assez
bon jean guy 10 par rapport à ce qui
s'est passé réellement c'était une
surprise un faut le dire le soir de la
draft là on l'a ou moins jeu égal chez
manuvie 9e j'ai bien dit damon darts à
salamanque ouest et lammers et la palme
d'or 3 attends je vais aller voir alors
je les aborde le pic pote 2021 gelé
effectivement alors là dire dans trois
mois qu'elle aborde sait que le bois
c'est vraiment une question de potentiel
l'américain coûte un peu plus fictif
dedans probabilité etc
board 13e je l'avais pierre 3 donc le
tiers calais de kata 15 donc bas du
tiers 3 vraiment bas du tyran c'est ça
alors c'est le plus haut qu ils étaient
7 37 chez bms est plus proche toi tu
n'avais 13e sur ton je retombe world
alex laver notre ami de jeudi il avait
dix neuvième n'étaient pas les plus il
ya la phase iii que maintenu les propres
aux métaux on est moins ces instruments
je m'élance un mot qui est beaucoup plus
haut parce que voilà il va lui dire à
lui d'autres choses je pense que c'est
un joueur qui l'a pressé peut-être pas
mais qu'il voyait quand même le type de
joueur que ça pouvait être la nba c'est
ça donc effectivement voilà on avait un
jour plus bas finalement c'est ben qui
toujours le plus proche il est choisi au
style peu de surprises à ce moment là
parce que on s'attendait à voir
honnêtement aucune gas
gas qui tombait plutôt nono la plupart
de faire la plupart des mots-clés grave
que vous voyez des bourdes toi tu sais
que tu avais notre ami notre ami
beau ouais j'aurais pris on est
honnêtement alors y était mentir trois
salles et donc de barnes hamoudi que
j'avais en 15 ou trois qu'un de ces
jours là mais il ya quand même des
préférences c'est à dire que j'aurais
draf traitement de faire des rares
j'aurais drafté kumming à boutenac zaïre
williams devant ceux de devant demande
de jd je pense
montrée peut-être même peut-être un
johnson peut-être même câble chômage moi
j'étais devancé voilà mais c'était les
gens reconnaît dans le même temps le
groupe de joueurs pros le second avant
pâques au sein de diffuser de césure
qu'est ce qui peut expliquer justement
qu'il était si bas par rapport à ce qui
s'est passé et est ce qu'aujourd'hui si
tu devais alors si tu devais refaire la
draft en te disant que tu as vu
maintenant plus de films de jazz qui dit
est ce que tu leur diras ferait toujours
aussi bas ou est-ce que tu le à peu près
la même position
je l'aurais l'autre dans mon top 10 et
qu'en fait je le monte à l'intérieur
demande faire 3 je le montrais et je le
garderais tiers 3-3 pour moi j'essaie en
fait je labellise métier rejet des
appels font ça beaucoup plus intéressant
d'emprunter moins assez souvent et donc
pour moi tiers 3 c starter plus pour moi
c'est à terme ce quelque chose qu'il est
je pense je vois pas le potentiel
all-star le potentiel all nba c'est jean
et je vois un starter plus intitulé un
très bon titulaire ce qui est déjà très
bien quand ton art au premier tour donc
sur ça ces notables par contre les
éléments sur lesquels
j'avais quelques doutes je suis pas
extrêmement rassurer je suis extrêmement
rassurés sur ce que je pensais qu'il
allait bien faire je suis pas très
rassuré sur les soucis que je
programmais en termes athlétique en
termes de haendel en termes de tir voilà
je suis pas extrêmement rassuré par
contre la commune cité a créé la
capacité à influer l'attak a fluidifié
le jeu sera pas du tout surpris il le
fait il arrive à le faire dans une
équipe avec beaucoup de turnover
beaucoup de rookie au coup de pot de
soucis donc c'est beaucoup beaucoup de
crédit à lui donner aussi sur son sac la
bonne terre de kobé se poser la question
c'est quoi ce guide je te laisse aller
sur le champ de tir de josh lui dit
qu'est ce qui te plaisais pas qu'est ce
que je peux déjà dire différence est
différent type de type web 2 504
chouchoute de joints et mécanique
ensuite sa capacité à se créer son
propre carré a sacré un décalage pour
prendre at / balandre est ce que tu peux
tu fais un peu de développer ce que je
pense dia je trouvais que mécaniquement
il y avait un souci là le positionnement
du ballon le jeu de l'action des jambes
c'est vrai que ce n'était pas naturel
par internet soit je pense que c'est un
joueur chez les jeunes quel corps était
un peu plus grand à ce point jeune
australien qui tempête le plus physique
je pense qu'il pouvait faire un petit
peu ce qu'ils voulaient donc qu'ils
pouvaient driver tout ça cette année ses
25 % 3 points sur 180 tentative ses 66
pour commencer francs c'est pas digne
d'un joueur qui porte la ballerine kg et
honnêtement et c'est un joueur qui est
très jeune donc sur le tir j'ai pas être
déçu mais j'ai pas être assurée non plus
parce que je voyais pas induire la
terreur je voyais en lui par contre un
joueur qui avait montré d'eiffage deux
touchés sur du flotteur sur du line up
et sa gelée vu aussi un petit peu parce
que comme il est grand il peut mais on
peut se poser cette zone intermédiaire
donc ça je l'avais vu en en
nba et le tir honnêtement c'est hazard
qui va pas sur la ligne 57 lancers
francs tentés en 1400 minutes cette
année rime biais donc c'est un souci et
c'est un joueur qui est à 25% à 3 points
cette année
je sais pas si tu as la répartition pas
là durant quelques minutes tout est ce
que tu sais à peu près est-ce que c'est
beaucoup de catch and shoot en fin de
saison a joué sur
les commentaires du chat on a un profil
qui le dit je me rappelle quand j'étais
déçu lors de la draft ok si après fergie
10 au lieu d'emmener toute une gamme
alors c'est vrai que c'était peut-être
la première grosse surprise on avait
mini surprise rapport aux mots classique
on avait 80% c'est hier matin contre 80%
de ces tirs s'est engagé toute l'année
3,82 lagune 6 % d'accord donc
effectivement on est beaucoup jours de
la fin de chaîne et très peu de
situations
avec très peu de situations où il prend
la balle il se crée son propre décalage
derrière un écran ou bien sûr du même
genre cette step cette bague est
présenté à 3 3 donc je disais la
principale surprise c'est des petites
surprises colis barnes qui était prix de
vente
tout naturel et demandé pardon par notre
pensée
moi je l'avais même j'avais poussé le
vice à d'abord c'est ça d'avoir en deux
salut et
ensuite deuxième petite surprise c'est
notre ami nommé jack goody qui tombe qui
tombe en 6 devant devant kumming à et
boucle est bouclée j'allais beaucoup
plus bas après je sais que je par
rapport à toi je l'avais bien plus bas
well raison de ma faible je trouvais
trop problématique on ne dit beaucoup de
meneur arrière ok si mal et ne devrait
bouger rapidement vers les spurs alors
et au mal et donc je ne sais pas où ils
pourraient aller 5 et une connexion avec
le tony parker l'asvel mais on va
espérer qu'ils puissent jouer beaucoup
de beaux coups derrière vous mais c'est
très mal
voilà ce que j'allais bien on a notre
ami jegx alexander
on a très mal de flo rida capin de
l'excellent créateur individuelle pour
se créer une séparation on à lugano
sorte qu'il veut tenir le plus le ballon
on a été au mal et dont on a deux kitty
rire ou en taille du multiple qui plus
quand même sur un jour qui peut exister
en catch and shoot du jardinier rien il
ya vu si tu as you grow major michael
ballack algues y met toi cette
transition plus fait de voir partager la
balle comment tu as senti le jour là
dessus j'ai été agréablement surpris ils
puissent aussi bien
ça marche aussi bien avec chez avec
dorthe sanchez en dorthe avec man alors
les deux matches qu'on a qu'on a clippé
donc c'est contre minnesota et c'est
contre cleveland il ya un match avec qui
j'ai un match 100 ch et je trouvais ça
intéressant si une fois ci peut alors en
termes de contexte on a aussi des
minutes on le voit est en gros le leader
du banc donc il faire un petit peu plus
tôt des buts où il joue beaucoup étaient
titulaires donc tous les contextes et je
trouve que dans tous les contextes
il est légitime chose tient à son âge
déjà il fait quelque chose de positif
est plus difficile c'est à pas le jeu et
rexel je te veux dans un rookie dans un
environnement reconstruction c'est déjà
très important et sur ça je suis
agréablement surpris parce que moi je
l'avais vu qu'avec la balle porteur de
balle je pense que chez les jeunes
australie faisait beaucoup ça aussi ça
va être la première fois que l'adq qui
doit avoir un contexte de la sorte et
donc ça je pense que c'est notable est
très important quand il appelle pelouse
je ne peux pas tirer qu'est-ce qui est
ce qu'il faut c'est des discours
ikuo pivot rebond offensif et lille il
va si beaucoup de choses il fait
beaucoup de choses parce que et là pour
la pose d'écrans sais pas ce qui m'a le
plus marqué mais c'est la capacité à
attaquer leurs gonds
bien se placer coupé
n'est pas toujours dans le mouvement
mais c'est un joueur intelligent un
gentil sent un peu le jeu qui sont un
peu les choses et donc sur ça il est ce
qu'il est il est très très bien là
dessus
sans il sent vraiment le sens vraiment
le hissant et s'en ressent un qi basket
vraiment développer tout le monde a
parlé de ça passe là mercredi soir pour
égaliser contre dallas très triste coup
d'oeil et tout ça c'est un petit peu si
on veut un microcosme ou pas c'est le
départ sorte de sa de sa saison mais
voilà c'est un peu simple le délire
essais il est vraiment vraiment
incroyable sociaux sur l'oeil qu'il a la
capacité à comprendre à lire à anticiper
à créer dépassement c'est ce que j'aime
chez lui c'est des mecs comme la mélodie
des mecs comme tijd c'est des mecs comme
luca s'est il est passé avec
anticipation la passe et quand elle part
elle est pâle elle arrive pas là où le
joueur qui est le réceptionnaire de la
passe et déjà il crée l'ouverture et
crédit créé l'espace est ce assez c'est
tellement rare que l'on pouvait noter
que ça se trouve à lui beaucoup ont volé
le ballon là où le jour doit être est
pas là où il est sa note d'humour
fluidifier comme tu le vois avec ça
c'était
deux beaux gosses là qui devenait du
coup notre notre symbole d'autres
égéries jérôme héraud dur ici je regarde
un petit j'espère faire le serveur d'un
des live
avec lov beaucoup d'amour pour lui
effectivement on gagne on avait aussi
ses portes un peu du ballon pour les
gîtes pour cacher ce qui est important
des balles
à renaud hinse donc plus un finisseur
mamadou diakité d'origine ya donc
j'avais beaucoup d'espoir qui confirme
malheureusement même si rémy robinson
qui touche un peu la balle dans les
commentaires on a du coup deux rebonds
offensifs amat c'est pas mal surtout
avec ce profil ouais un jour très long
qui sont pleins de jeux qui comprend
bien qui peut être là où il faut on nous
dit aussi alexis la impressionnant sans
ballon et se déplace bien comprendre le
jeu très intelligente il n'a pas
l'intelligence de ne pas rester sans
bouger à trois points voilà c'est ça
c'est des joueurs effectivement qui
rendent compte qu'on était pas une
menace extérieure qu est ce que tu peux
qu'est-ce que tu pas porter de plus
comment est ce que tu peux faire
valoriser le tout est ce que tu arrive
justement à
créer de la menace quelque chose qui
manque ce truc bête ans et voilà mais
qu'on attend de russell westbrook au
niveau des lakers et que recevraient que
n'arrive n'est pas encore en capacité
d'amener de caen je paye ma d'assortir
qu'est-ce que je peux faire dans mon
mouvement dans l'été place donc pour
améliorer le tout et ça ce qu'il fait
très bien un mec comme bruce brand
notamment qu ex très bien mais comme on
lui demande ce que fait pas un mec comme
blé de sault et que moi j'ai espoir
qu'une équipe pourra peut-être
développer aux et des écrans rôle et ont
donc roulé vers le cerf coupé il faut
citer pas et si on peut citer pas le
tireur de l'équipe donc le seul nom
tireurs sur les postes externe a pu donc
une chance de jouer avec un autre grand
qui peut être n'est pas non plus un tir
à 3 points donc tout à fait
potentiellement deux noms tireurs de nos
shooteurs dans le sac il faut que tu
fasses des choses parce que sinon ce
passing l attaque ça va être vraiment
comment c'est moins compliqué de chez
moi je le vois par exemple entre saint
john terry newton tu connais bien qu'ils
essaient d'en là dedans là où j'ai
patrick williams qui a besoin d'un autre
jeu mais qui manque encore d'agressivité
sur le panier
lorsqu'il était même dans le monde du
ballon donc c'est pas quelques forcément
quelque chose de stars mais c'est
quelque chose qui est juste 30 ans des
bâtiments meilleur et que faire la
bascule dit j'espère que les plaisirs
seront donc réussir le faire bien jouer
de kenzo à ablis des sceaux fait savoir
qu'ils y restent notre image mais
je pense qu'il faudra mais ils ont
récupéré un gars d'ailleurs j'ai eu un
moment il n'y a pas d'autre occasion je
vous mets même ma tête est en train de
célébrer comme ça regardez moi en bill
walton
freaky johnson fut fort qin qian sound
il est libre messieurs dames cet homme
est libre cet homme va jouer cet homme
va nous régaler cet homme va vous
montrer pourquoi cette optique de draft
et c'est la fin de ma parenthèse sur kim
johnsson regardez le sepa tony stèle qui
va lui prendre son poste de titulaire
pendant très longtemps moi je vous dis
voilà les lancers maintenant pour
revenir sur le principal josh qui dit on
va pouvoir enchaîner du couchois force
qui nous intéresse sur le sur la vidéo
je repasse ça ici du coup en vidéo tu
nous as dit que tu as fait jour de match
avec sg 1 et stargate et l'autre sont
choqués minnesota de match la maison
minnesota et cleveland parce qu'on peut
ses ministres dans cette équipe sans par
les équipes sans travail il y en a c'est
un peu en bleu à autre d'autres c'est un
vrai match le match au garden fait 10
passes d il est incroyable points dans
de bons donc mal son coin équidés et
solide bond dans l'est dans les deux
matchs donc été
un plaisir et ce parc est incroyable ce
parc est incroyable de ce truc racing je
trouve incroyable et s2 blanc crème gris
ci-dessous ça change ça change mais
c'est plaisant et les furets sont ainsi
c'est bien quand tu vois mais ouais le
gri gri gri et après je vais être je
suis désolé les fans des deux clubs à
city mais c'est vraiment l'équipe
leur design ça n'a jamais plus quoi
j'aime pas leur maillot
jaune par la mosquée beaucoup de
beaucoup de fans d'amy fan dok ici donc
tu de jeu j'aime bien qu'ici je suis
ministre l'attitude bien si tu t'en
reste
salut moi c'est pas très grave il
n'arrête pas de faire des points communs
gauche c'est un croyant je laisserais
bien tournée du coup à fond pour mon
trac monde et reprend à faire du clip a
clippé sur ces matches-là sur quoi notre
dos concentré qu'est-ce que tu va
vouloir nous montrer particulièrement
sur qu'est ce qui t'a dit vraiment
c'était ce qui est un peu tout la
capacité à faire des placements à gauche
parce que c'est un des meilleurs de la
nyc passeur de la main opposée vraiment
la main qui n'est pas la sienne de base
la capacité à faire des renversements
des kick out et il est déjà incroyable
la vision est aussi on encore se rendre
compte qu'il n'est pas aidé par ses
coéquipiers donc seul et donc que les
statistiques les stades box corps et au
four il faut regarder les matches parce
que les fans de gossip s'époumone tous
les soirs j'ai l'impression à dire non
il est bien meilleur il devrait avoir
beaucoup plus de passes il a fait qu'un
seul triple double année parce qu'il ya
des fois il n'est pas aidé par les
passes des finitions sont pas sont pas
incroyable et qu'est-ce qu'on a regardé
aussi un peu les problèmes physiques des
problèmes de haendel haut niveau et
didier parent bah voilà il se fait
vraiment facilement bloquée sur le point
d'attaquer ils n'arrivent pas créé de
séparation et donc voilà tout ça est un
peu mis en exergue ce coup
là bonne défense couvre un peu dans le
clip défensif mais un ou deux on voit de
la bonne rotation la coutelas la
capacité à créer à avoir l'oeil à créer
des affaires créer le décalage
adversaire parce qu'il se passe bien et
les grandes on voit pas ce que je donne
sa défense si c'est qu'il est capable de
remporter la bonne est juste de venir
proposer une aide de venir proposer une
réception le ballon pour faire réfléchir
le porteur de balle circule sur la
pénétration dans l'axé par exemple
j'aime beaucoup cette capacité à venir
hop je me place jade et je reprends pour
donner une hésitation et crée un peu de
défense collective on le dit dans le
wagon chat
donc darius la finition d'un espace
l'est effectivement si les intérieures
tia maria référence dmard cityrama les
robinson on n'avait pas de briques à la
place des mains pour retirer mal acquis
qui a un début compliqué alors que
c'était un joueur très intéressant à
brenda alors docteur sa garde qui sait
qui s'est fait comment dire modéré par
le bot pas ce qu'il a dit alors il a dit
je vais le dire en anglais puis plus
loin quatrième lettre de l'alphabet
proder passes décisives mais n'écrivez
pas ça le bot pour ce que vous êtes
homophobe attention à vous on était
assists on va pouvoir du coup regardez
maintenant un peu le clip en
individuel il enregistre qu'on ne va pas
voir trop de décalage pour ça alors je
repasse si je vais me repérer avec la
couleur du parquet par axel premiers
mois là c'est le premier
11 05 donc là tu es sûr de la création
de sons de la passe décisive avec les
deux mains lui s'en fiche pour lui sans
vie des deux groupes ils s'en fichent
complètement
pas le niveau de tellement niveau de
wendel s'est il est plus vraiment droit
sow mais
c'est vraiment sur la qualité de passe
au cm1 droite comme à gauche il s'en
fiche un peu là on est sûr
tranquille ou alors la planche c'est un
joueur assez à l'ancienne ce trou je
regarde les finitions les angles qui
trouve toujours des années 80
que je disais c'est un joueur atypique
et c'est ça qui fait tout son charme je
pensais tout ce qui est cool c'est bien
d'avoir des genres différents et que
posséder des jeux différents et lui il
détonne un peu par sa dent dans l'ère
des super combo guard créateurs sur
pick'n roll qui poulet pas d'y mettre
mal il est un peu différent l'intitulé
mais un short court mais des boston
celtics et baky koné 70 sans
gravité bas et des peintures de taille
artisanale archibald et 22,3 bagdad 70
car la copie très drôle on est sûr de
capacités qui dans le corner avec prend
l'appellation visuel
alors que le clip il va revenir excusez
moi ce qui me met pas en boucle non
c'est vous
donc à capacité du
tarn et sur la transition voilà six ans
que tu m'entends et sur la transition
pas simple les gars tout le temps et j
aime et sait qu'il ya dort dans le
corner c'est simple et efficace il a pas
non plus les murs les meilleurs
catcheurs shooter du monde à côté jusque
dans le projet d'occident 3 4 ans quand
tu auras l'intérieur pour pop quand tu
auras des shooteurs il sera encore plus
plus létal là dessus et je voie de
l'être je voyais beaucoup que des russes
belges avaient bien qu'un riche ou bien
parce que j'adore à la passe pour
qualifier un incroyable c'est à la fin
c'est passé un peu vrai ça arrive sur un
trois points de crem annoncé donc c'est
bien celui qui fait la passe décisive
c'est s'est fait la passe avant la
basilique mais elle est super mais
franchement la main gauche à l'opposé
comme ça et aller à séoul à du pick and
roll avec biz les enrôlements et un kick
out pour très mal
reçue par adjoint tim ouais c'est un
créateur individuelle supérieure notre
aile très bonnes c'est jouer
collectivement etc mais enfin tu l'avais
à ses autres émane du souvenir là on est
chauds louer niveau des coéquipiers
après
ouais on est souvent là des choses qui
élit gens qui arrivent pas à finir mais
la passade est bonne elle a passé à
terre pick and roll - gauche
orientations pour gérer mais robinson
est une très bonne lecture et donc jour
quelqu'un pas au bout de
ses fers toutes les passes y'a pas une
passe je trouve qu'il maîtrise pas déjà
comme la mélodie la mélodie c'est faire
toutes les passes le cas il sait faire
toutes les passes
kate pour moi il sait quasiment faire
toutes les passes aussi et donc
c'est rare mais c'est plus et de moins
en moins rare j'ai l'impression
d'ailleurs avec tous ces jeunes porteurs
de balle et c'est quand vraiment quand
tu vois les matches la même action après
action quart-temps après quart temps que
tu le vois qu'ils maîtrisent pas parce
qu'en fait une allemande tombeau de tous
les niveaux at il dit
mais en fait on parle d'eux s'est passé
dès demain une capacité de passer on
passe direct pas snober passe au sol
capacité de passer là où le joueur doit
être
capacité à manipuler visuellement cette
nature ne pas regarder là où tu vas
faire passer derrière et puis événement
qui voile alors ça que nous dans nos
jours dans nos évaluations et un joueur
qui est capable de tout faire ça nous
mettrait trop
exemple moi je sais que j'ai des sens et
après on va discuter tout bientôt
j'utilise un peu mais je descends un peu
un tight à washington qui est un
excellent passeur qui elle un passeur de
bones passion pick-and-roll incroyable
et qui est pas foutu de passer à une
main sur sa main forte et ça me rend fou
la fête de provocant kansas la semaine
dernière j'ai pensé à toi pour matin un
replay mais c'est c'était une des
premières heures de l'année complètement
en voit aussi en transition il ya une
solution enfants et les grands à l'heure
s'il a donné une solution profite qui 15
pour d'orthe là il va où il y va il
finit au cercle là j'adore ce qu'ils
sont ce qui va arriver au bon français
de ces espèces de passes au sol qui est
fait là on l'a donnée à un pays libre
c'est un nom que ces personnes décédées
après il ya et le compostage en moins
c'est leur pouvoir a pas très bon
derrière sur la page pense que le rebond
lors d un petit point derrière parce que
j'ai un petit peu de tekken fin un peu
d'avancé mais le rebond n'a pas su
reprendre invisible et mais l'intention
le fait de l'envoyer devant le palau
baiser et dans la halle dans la course
ouais ce petit rebond là qui le gêne il
pour le dribble assez bas mais
et puis derrière du coup il finit avec
une banane et c'est bien suivi une faute
mais voilà on projette vers l'avant on
est vraiment dans le rythme de la tacc
traitement là on est content cleveland
donc tu es de bonne équipe a remis cet
accueil en musique ont plus de talents
coq est ici mais ces deux et deux fois
où sur le parquet voilà deux guides et
très bon là ça cette action est mort
c'est une très belle passe à l'opposé un
oeil sur aube offensif dont la dette à
l'heure on regarde juste ici on voit la
balle est dans les mains de jort ça lui
va apparaître directement il dit avant
moi le ballon c'est moi qui vais créer
donc la pièce présentée ici on est sur
une zone au sein de petites zones de
cleveland séparément une zone mais si
l'aco là on est clairement en zone qui
va très bien d'ailleurs aux demandes
quant à trois grands comme ça mais je
pensais qu'ils allaient vraiment tout en
défendant de 3 tu vois montre de
siffloter finalement début de la saison
ils ont fait beaucoup de dégâts et val
perdre et il fallait qu'ils défendent
comme ça et c'est vraiment un sens quand
un coach qu'il a des idées
complètement donc sonné chez lasserre
way voie lactée en dribbles et manque
d'explosivité là marc stephens
proxénètes qui dépensent un très bon
défenseur sans actionner de
samara bon défenseur c'est pas un cadeau
pour dodig idée mais ya pas de crier
aucune création de séparation a aucune
ya pas de vivacité sur le premier pas là
pas de burst et les en donner un peu à
part donc ça c'est les axes de progrès
il le battra jamais là sur le la
capacité à albas tract de manière
athlétique mais il faut grâce à son
hymne della riva secret de la séparation
est ce que j'ai dit ce que je vais te
dire c'est qu'en fait finalement les
gens qui sont pas athlétique c'est un
truc qui s'est dévaluée de plus en plus
et de les monter voici ces mecs là
deuxième vingt parce que des bases
utilisées à ses pas dans mes moque
d'être un meneur pourtant demain tout
cas créateurs mais sans être explosif il
faut être fluide dans le petit dribble
faut savoir naviguer pamina de façon
insolite et gérer le tempo lui c'est un
bon gestionnaire de tempo après il n'est
pas aidé parce que j'avais des choix de
dissocier parce qu'ils vont attendre de
lui les plus chaudes drôle où il sera
plus en contrôle du coup il lui faut un
intérieur dominant capable de créer du
décalage mais il faut qu'ils puissent
naviguer plus fortement parce qu'on voit
hélas pas la diversité comme tu l'as dit
il a pas non plus la puissance pour
prendre le dessus musculairement sur des
joueurs plus petit que lui
donc je pense que ce sera jamais la
danse qui sera un jour disent
non
complètement là il ya une très belle
rotation à trèbes à la rotation
défensive une bonne lecture diaries va
bien et fasse la remarque à rennes il
embête vraiment et c'est un système qui
est dessiné pour mark kent et hilary
vise pas bien mackenzie de lâcher la
balle et il sait que ils voient qu'ils à
cocoa va pénétrer il vient une très
belle rotation des bras levés une fois
rien à dire là-dessus comme ce qui est
intéressant aussi c'est la lecture
rapide c'est alors que la couronne ait
pas une menace d'autant que tirs à trois
points donc je vais venir contester le
drive hop je reste bertic
donc l'année en maintenant la passe en
transition avec le petit cafouillage des
deux coéquipiers d'abord
c'est robinson elle ou d'ordre
river et robinson et son terrain s'est
pas méga fréquents je trouve du côté
qu'il les deux jours ensemble et là
c'est voir la capacité qu'a il le fait
bien ça aussi se mettre devant son
défense devant son défenseur dribbler
bas les flotteurs crie ça c'est un truc
chris paul est mort explique paul james
james harden à une époque aussi parce
que ça résonne classe ouais ouais c'est
vrai c'est vrai c'est vrai complètement
cassé je sais pas c'est pas des paniers
faciles mais c'est des paniers ou hype
et il peut il peut un peu influencé son
scoring en est un et 8-1 n'est pas de
chasser ça que je te parle de naviguer
paloma et de gérer le tempo a été wells
on doit le prénom est excellent là
dedans je reviens encore une fois sur
l'action et j'ai essayé de friser un peu
on vote rôle le dribble en contrôler le
rythme on est capable de changer de
direction dans son ballon
il ya l'écran je frise capable de passer
sur la main droite contrôler et on a
aussi lors la paix sociale qui pourrait
arriver j'ai frisé sur l'action ce que
diaries halliburton fait très très bien
aussi en n'étant pas un menu hyper
explosif est-ce que tu as tes washington
fera merveille l'année prochaine la
passe au niveau du sol capacité à gérer
ça parce que finalement je sais pas ce
que tu en penses mais dans 90% des cas
en nba jour du pick and roll 1,5 ou
défendre up en fait ce fantasme de la
switch revenant régulièrement la forme
de lyre en saison régulière c'est clair
il n'y a pas d' adaptation défensive
surtout pour des jeunes joueurs comme ça
ce fantasme la switch habilité 1,5 c pas
une réalité aujourd'hui
est qu en fait la plupart des gens
défendent en europe et donc les meneurs
nous athlétiques comme ça arrive à se
créer leur propre espace en tout cas par
le par l'écran il ya un hymne between et
c'était bon dans le mid réalité vous
dans le flotteur c'était bon dans la
passe au sol donc gestion du compte on
pas contrôle du tempo de la gestion tu
peux être un mec très efficace et on le
voit avec ta louise halliburton on ne
voit et chris paul on le voit du coup
avec j'ai dit ici
est ce que j'ai un autre exemple en tête
là comme ça en tout cas vous voyez les
palais me noël qui est qu'elle est
effectivement l effet très très bien
l'ag a lieu deux semaines vous que l'an
dernier j'avais wee de magog j'avais
baissé parce que je pensais pas que ça
peut être un deux meneurs et pareil pour
son explosivité dans l'axé nord-sud et
finalement soit man et tourne à 8 passes
décisives par match parce qu'ils jouent
avec gucci beach qui est pas un pivot
qui pose des fraises écran et qui est
capable de marquer près du panier à
distance et c est donc la différence nba
sont autant du drop et donc par sa
gestion par son contrôle il arrive alors
d espace 2 vous est donc maintenant
comme sage apprend aussi à are value et
un petit peu pour moi pour qu'un mec qui
est pas explosif puisse être même une
menace balle en main faut que sois
inavic très bien ce que fait le chef qui
dit ici soit faut qu'il soit une
bourride physique le cas d'annecy çetin
des cadeaux aussi internautes étant le
le combo parfait de je maîtrise le tempo
de foule je navigue parfaitement avec la
balle et je suis physique qui prend le
dessus je vous lis tu mets tous les
défenseurs des rues ont maintenant
un affreux catherine shoot à trois
points des mets en montrer quand même un
ou deux gestes on va revenir dessus il
était que l'aca toutes et tous et c'est
vrai oui c'est un push en chat quand il
pousse à bâle alors les mâles sont
prêtes
voilà il se met dans le camp des risques
inutiles dans le corner ici les mâles
sont elles sont prêtes alors au niveau 2
au niveau des pieds tout est poussif et
en os ont vraiment appuyé le ballon vers
l'avant
bon bah non il ya peu qui fait ça qui
fait ça actuellement le vent en bus en
extérieur à paris
j'ai pas trop après on a discuté a pas
très longtemps du côté de nicolas et
avait dans le parc de la planète draft
avec romain et c est ce que tu puisses
investir est ce que toi tu crois qu'en
plus d'avoir un travail oui bien sûr
bien sûr pas faire ce qu'on peut avant
est ce que c'est moi passe préféré à
jovetic à haute main gauche tanguay tu
peux y pèse ou entre deux trois
défenseurs et en l'air et qui 40 ma
gauche
et sagesse à cela toute sa créativité la
créativité qui va pointer à la
mecque muscles evans john terry tout
c'est souvent hyper positif alors c'est
pendant le projet web et chaque fois
qu'il rentre sur le terrain il se passe
des fins la porte du spacing ça permet
aussi à ça permet aux petits de alors du
splitting un mec qui peut mettre des
tirs et donc fait comme toujours
contents même temps les équipes en
reconstruction
il m'interdisait que vous voulez plus de
trélazé de kill you think pour quelqu'un
de gamme on est dans cette idée là quoi
2 donner de l'espace à vos joueurs à vos
jeunes
du coup voilà dans le bilan du coup de
ce2 ce joueur est ce que qu'elles sont
pour toi les axes de développement
auquel tu crois vraiment et pour toi ou
est ce qu'il arrivera jamais et
et si tu dois faire un peu son son nom
sous plafond est ce que tu penses qu'il
peut vraiment devenir l'imaginons dans
un autre contexte avec jallet ce qui
peut devenir important de valve
principale de sein d'une équipe
compétitive
non je pense pas je pense par contre que
c'est un jeu qui après une longue
carrière nba sera toujours utile dans
une rotation ce que les deux axes de
progression sont tirés le dribble pour
compenser le profil athlétique mais je
pense qu'il sera il aura toujours un
rôle parce que il est actif loin du
ballon il fait des très bonnes bases il
bouge il comprend il sent le jeu et donc
je pense que avec un intérieur capable
de faire du pick and pop avec des
shooteurs avec chay qui va est parfois
un peu sur courant alternatif cette
année ce qui est pas tout un monde qui
des mois je pense que ça va vraiment les
gens que ça peut être ton quatrième je
pense que ça peut être ton je peux voir
un sorte de destins l'arrêt kyrou burma
pour lui on est donc
prenez beaucoup de lait mais le goal est
ce que fait seulement l'objectif c'est
pas les boules
ouais c'est lonzo c'est ricky rubio je
pense que ce genre de joueur la gamme
qui peut être à son prime site a une
très bonne équipe et en quatrième et en
cinquième starter joue le titre
est ce que le côté défensif physique le
fait de cp-ce hier pour pouvoir tenir un
peu plus ses duels et du coup lui ont
valu demandez sûrement de défendre des
ailiers
à terme puisqu'il ya un problème comme
de latéralité pouvoir défendre des
extérieurs est-ce que ça tu crois lui
fait de pouvoir renforcer ce basso du
corps et tenir au contact des joueurs
qui sont pour l'instant plus puissante
lui
sa part voir avec son métabolisme avec
sa musculature mais je pense oui je
pense que ce sera fin nba c'est ça aussi
ça doit se faire ça sera fait ou s'ils
sont des noms sinon wire a dépossédé des
petits problèmes mais je pense que comme
il sait comme il est grand il pourra il
peut jouer peut-être avec des et
il faut qui s'épaississent parce que
comme il est grand pour le mettre avec
le plus petit et laissera les plus
petits qui s'occuperont des porteurs de
balle adverse une fois qu'ils soient pas
s'il sera jamais sur les deux meilleurs
attaquants
de l'équipe adverse mais je pense qu'il
peut devenir non négatif on va dire on
est gay on va dire ça serait bien des
gens est ce que tu vas quand je regarde
ce qu'il a fait sur le remarque anne
laure il marque annan qui est un joueur
qui n'aime pas le contact de bosses mais
qui est comme un puissant il va pas
souvent parce que c'est pas qu'il doit
il se casse mais il est quand même assez
puissante choix c'était intéressant
cette cette gestion choix des mouvements
uniforme au jour des joueurs qui ne
change pas de direction et c'est de
pouvoir le tenir moi je les ai vus
contre chicago ya pas très longtemps je
trouve quand même qui fait un voile
ailleurs dans les rotations
effectivement c'est bien mais on a mis
un peu sur des maraudes et rosanne il
cependant les feintes il peut premier
peuple voilà john yoo dit n'est pas si
frêle que si on refuse pas le contact je
n'ai pas de doute sur le fait qu'ils
puissent progresser physiquement moi je
pense que ça peut être un acte
amélioration très intéressant et à ce
moment là on est vraiment chaud du
profil à la launch the bull qui devenu
un tir exceptionnel mais avec un peu
plus je trouve de fluidité de créativité
dans le dribble dans l'ombre de la all
the bullet un qui refuse d'entre d'eux
qui va propane et médicaments non plus
l'autre
un bon bah écoutes je pense qu'on a fait
un petit tour d'horizon sympa j'espère
que non le chat le l'image qu'on décrit
de djezzy et projets tels que vous voyez
dans les matches
et si vous avez des nôtres question j'ai
vu pas mal de choses on nous dit que
tout était ok si ce serait incroyable
filet presque parfait alors tu y es tu
le fais tu es parfait non dans trente
équipes nba
mais même si tu as les jours un peu un
peu plus bas si tu penses tu vas les
intérieurs qui peuvent arriver moi je le
vois très bien vous les cabas wyss mais
ce serait incroyable pour le specis
djendjen quitte à un joueur je parle des
intérieurs dans le top dans la loterie
ya dans la vie dignité quant au
challenge one apprendre à mettre un
écran correct ensuite ça lui laissera
des espaces on pourrait avoir une
relation
ce que dit entre elton a du côté de du
côté de phoenix avec notre ami chris
paul qui pourrait être sympa et puis si
on est aujourd'hui un projet john butler
john butler on est même cycle aller la
draft mais c'est pareil dans le dos
l'image du space x ça peut être sympa
aussi
complètement donc voilà bon bah écoutez
si vous avez d'autres romans vous me
dites moi je vais laisser un petit peu
tourner ça les clips non on peut lire en
même temps que je fais un petit tweet
rapidement pour dire qu'on passe au
prochain numéro 1 de la draft n'en
déplaise à certains
on est en grève et on va pouvoir en
débattre de ça et maintenant il peut pas
t'as vu son corps va pas tenir sacré il
n'est pas assez puissant c'est évident